[Aplausos]
yo vengo de una familia de policías mis
tíos son policías mi padre es policía y
recuerdo cuando yo de pequeño maté
alguna ocasión lo vi llegar con su
uniforme a mi casa cansado y en mata
alguna ocasión también le logré quitar
las botas porque él estaba demasiado
exhausto cuando yo lo veía me vi en
ellos en algún momento pero había
ciertas cosas que yo no comprendía por
el hecho de ser un niño cosas que
posteriormente llegaría a comprender en
el año de 2011 ingresó a la academia
para convertirme en policía y ahí fue
cuando me di cuenta que ser policía en
este país era algo más que portar un
arma una placa o un uniforme significaba
poder profesionalizarme estudiar código
penal procesal penal leyes especiales
tácticas teníamos que saber todo eso
porque un policía en la calle no puede
alegar ignorancia cuando está ejerciendo
la función de la seguridad pública de
toda una población
pero tenemos que comprender muchas cosas
y la primera es contextualizar qué es la
realidad de un policía cuando yo termino
la academia y me juramento en el año de
2012 habían muchas cosas que a lo mejor
ningún salvadoreño y mucho menos los
policías sabíamos que íbamos a enfrentar
y ahora el hecho que en los años
siguientes el salvador se iba a
convertir en el país más peligroso del
mundo con la mayor tasa de homicidios
por cada 100.000 habitantes en todo el
planeta y eso que nosotros no teníamos
un estado de guerra declarada ni de
conflicto armado a diferencia de otros
países como siria irak afganistán ahora
se imaginan lo que significó durante ese
tiempo ser policía en el país más
peligroso de la tierra eso fue mucho de
lo que enfrentamos y en ese entonces los
policías no sólo tenían que velar por la
seguridad de todos sino que también
tenían que evitar ser parte de este
gráfico este gráfico muestra los
homicidios de agentes policiales desde
el año 2009 hasta el año de 2018 podemos
ver la gráfica como esto empezó a
incrementar
en el año de 2015 llegó a su punto
máximo con 79 homicidios de agentes
policiales convirtiéndose la policía en
la institución gubernamental con un
mayor número de muertes violentas en la
historia de nuestro país
ahora se imaginarán cómo era en mi caso
cuando yo prestaba mi servicio en los
alcoholes del 9/11 en san salvador
cuando no tuve que ir a uno ni a dos
tampoco a tres ni a cuatro sino a cinco
actos fúnebres durante 2015 de hombres
con los que compartía más tiempo que con
mi misma familia por las largas jornadas
laborales me tocó ver a sus esposas a
sus hijos ya sus madres llorar sobre sus
féretros en algunos casos eran féretros
sellados por el estado de sus cuerpos
se imaginan cómo fue realmente para la
policía de ese tiempo y para personas
como nosotros que entramos con la idea
de cambiar nuestro país y ahora
enfrentábamos algo que teníamos que
encarar día con día y esa fue nuestra
realidad al final de todo este tiempo
quedó este número 415 agentes asesinados
entre 2009 y 2018 este número no sólo
representa una estadística de bajas en
una corporación también son 415 viudas
415 huérfanos o muchos más y 415 padres
y madres que tuvieron que enterrar a sus
hijos algo que ningún padre debería
hacer en esta vida
pero en qué entonces qué fue lo que
sucedió posterior a esto veamos en enero
de 2016 la fuerza operativa policial era
de 21 mil 718 elementos vamos a entender
como fuerza operativa a aquellos agentes
que vemos en las calles patrullando y a
los que no vemos pero que administran a
este personal para que sea eficiente
en julio de 2019 la fuerza operativa
policial era de 21 mil 550 entonces qué
fue lo que sucedió realmente porque
durante todo este tiempo estuvieron
graduando otras promociones de policías
por el número de descendió esto
significó que mucha gente renunció por
esta oleada de violencia entre los que
murieron que por lo menos en 415 más las
renuncias depuraciones etcétera ahora es
una situación que están solventándose
con la inyección de nuevos policías con
sangre nueva de personas que quieren
cambiar este país
ahora observen esto nuestro territorio
tiene 21 mil 040 kilómetros cuadrados y
si tomamos en cuenta el referente de
julio del año pasado que tenemos 21.550
policías a cada uno le correspondería
para salvaguardar el territorio nacional
un área de 0.97 kilómetros cuadrados
tomamos como referente el parque
bicentenario para quienes nos han
visitado alguna vez y pueden ver como
parece bastante difícil de creer que una
sola persona pudiera garantizar la
seguridad de un lugar de un bosque tan
denso como ese
pero tenemos que ver otro punto también
de los veintiún mil quinientos cincuenta
agentes operativos como en cualquier
otro trabajo tienen sus días de descanso
entonces mientras estas personas van a
descansar un aproximado de quince mil
policías se mantienen dando seguridad
diariamente a excepción de cuando haya
estado de calamidad o suspensión de
licencias entonces significa que si
dividimos nuestro territorio en la
cantidad de los 15.000 policías que dan
seguridad diariamente promedio el área
se extiende a 1.4 kilómetros cuadrados
por policía
ahora si aparece incluso más sub real
creer que una sola persona pudiera
garantizar la seguridad de todas las
personas dentro de un área de este
tamaño
ahora trasladamos esto mismo pero a una
zona urbana que les parece el estadio
mágico gonzález todos hemos ido a algún
concierto hemos ido a algún este partido
de fútbol y hemos visto la magnitud del
lugar ahora imagínense la extensión de
la colonia flor blanca también pero
imaginemos que no hay nadie allí cuando
un policía caminando como si fuese un
episodio de the walking dead' parece
bien difícil creer que solo él pudiera
garantizar la seguridad de un área tan
grande pero esto es sólo el 0 puntos 97
kilómetros ahora veamos en la misma área
urbana con el 1.4
a casi ya más o menos creo que nos
podemos hacer la idea porque a veces el
9/11 tarda en llegar cuando hacen
llamadas un solo policía debería cubrir
un área de la colonia centroamérica el
estadio mágico gonzález y luego hacia el
oriente llegando cerca de lo que sería
centro histórico aquí se hace vuelve
completamente absurdo pensar que un solo
policía pudiera garantizar la seguridad
de las miles de personas que viven en
todo este territorio
ahora bien estos son titulares de
periódicos locales de cuando patrullas
se mandaban solo con dos elementos como
podemos ver los resultados no fueron
positivos por el contrario muchos
murieron en estas situaciones y es
porque a veces en algunas partes no hay
suficientes personal y se tienen que
mandar sólo a dos entonces se tienen que
tener patrullas de tres o cuatro para
poder garantizar incluso su propia
seguridad y no estar en vulnerabilidad
pero qué significa esto que si junto
cuatro policías el área a cubrir puede
cuadruplicarse y acá es donde realmente
ahora podemos entender por qué a veces
cuesta que una patrulla llegue a un
lugar cuando están cubriendo un
territorio tan grande
ahora veamos esto el llamado del deber
para enero de este año la población de
nuestro país será de 6 millones 555 mil
31 habitantes si lo dividimos entre los
15 mil policías que dan seguridad
diariamente en nuestro país a cada
policía le correspondería la
responsabilidad de cuidar a 437
habitantes de nuestro territorio
imagínense eso es como que yo tuviera
que guardar la seguridad de todas las
personas en este auditorio y hasta los
que trabajan en el otro lado de la calle
para llegar a ese número y siendo muy
honestos a lo mucho pudiera garantizar
la seguridad personal de las primeras
cinco personas de la primera fila y
manteniéndola junto a mí para que yo
pudiera garantizar esa seguridad
entonces qué pasaría si estas 400 37
personas se cuestionarán a sí mismas y
se preguntarán qué es lo que puedo hacer
yo como un ciudadano para poder ayudar a
ese policía que representa a toda la
gente de mi colonia qué puedo hacer yo
pues bien podemos empezar con derrotar
los estigmas aquellas cosas que
separaron a los cuerpos de seguridad de
la sociedad veamos el primero una frase
célebre de las manifestaciones estudia
no seas policía y es muy curioso cuando
estudiantes que aún no tienen un grado
universitario le gritan eso a alguien
que ya es profesional en seguridad
pública que ahora sale con técnico en
ciencias policiales de la academia
muchos de ellos graduados de
universidades muchos son catedráticos
han representado a nuestro país en
mundiales de debate en competiciones
olímpicas entonces si tenemos una de las
policías más preparadas y profesionales
de toda latinoamérica y eso es algo muy
destacable y es algo que tenemos que ir
superando luego el siguiente los cuerpos
de seguridad en la guerra
quedó el estigma de los cuerpos antiguos
de seguridad sobre la policía cuando
muchos de nosotros no tenemos ni
siquiera 30 años no tuvimos nada que ver
en el conflicto armado y somos una nueva
generación de personas que realmente
queremos hacer una sociedad donde la
policía y la sociedad misma puedan
llevar a cabo una labor en conjunto y
luego todos son corruptos nosotros
sabemos que la policía no está exenta de
este problema de corrupción al igual que
cualquier otra entidad del estado pero
los mismos números reflejan que es un
pequeño porcentaje de policías y los
mecanismos que estos hacen para
depurarlos pero somos muchos más los que
día con día salimos de nuestras casas y
no sabemos si vamos a regresar porque
las probabilidades que tenemos de no
volver son mucho más grandes que la de
un ciudadano común y algunos si logran
regresar a sus casas pero regresan sin
sus piernas
regresan sin su ojo regresan con alguna
parálisis cuando fueron dañados en
combate sin embargo esos son muchos de
los estigmas que tenemos que superar
y ahora los héroes y heroínas donde
todos nos hemos visto alguna vez todos
en algún momento hemos tenido una
fantasía alguna vez cuando nos hemos ido
a dormir qué pasaría si hoy se meten los
ladrones en la casa y por primera vez
ocupar el bate que tengo ahí guardado y
amarrar al ladrón y se lo entregó a la
policía me condecoraron o me subo al
autobús y luego que se sube un sujeto
raro me pongo a pensar bueno si tres
hombres más se levantarán creo que yo lo
desarmar ahí lo entregaría la policía
seríamos el héroe del día y créanme que
a veces el heroísmo va más allá de un
acto altruista a veces hay muchas
acciones que nosotros no sabemos que
tiene un impacto trascendental en la
sociedad y en la seguridad misma de toda
una población ahora veamos cuáles
pudieran ser estos todo suma y todo
cuenta lo que nosotros hagamos realmente
en nuestro país y a veces son cosas que
no tenemos ni la menor idea que
realmente lo tienen así que les voy a
pedir tres cosas hoy que podemos
intentar juntos como sociedad la primera
no voten basura en la calle
se preguntarán si pero qué tiene que ver
esto con la seguridad pública pues tiene
que ver con algo porque esto es algo
cultural esto es algo en lo que si yo al
botar la basura me doy cuenta que eso va
a causar un declive ambiental que va a
afectar a mi sociedad que va a afectar a
mi colonia puedo empezar posteriormente
de es de modificar ese comportamiento a
modificar otros y así como sociedad
empezar a salir adelante este es un buen
punto de partida el siguiente respeta el
reglamento de tránsito y en serio por
favor respeten lo les voy a poner un
ejemplo de que tan trascendental es esto
imagínense la patrulla de dos policías
que andan patrullando 1.4 kilómetros
cuadrados un sector con siete colonias y
de repente se le ocurre el tío pasarse
la doble línea amarilla porque olvidó el
reglamento de tránsito y chocó y a lo
mejor era un choque leve que costaba que
20 dólares la reparación pero necesitan
la inspección para que el seguro llegue
y lo cobre entonces esta patrulla va a
tener que abandonar su sector de
responsabilidad
para dar custodia a la escena del
accidente y esperar a que llegue el
móvil de tránsito que probablemente va a
tener diez accidentes en cola de
personas que también se les volvió al
reglamento y va a tener que estar dos
horas ahí qué va a pasar con esas siete
colonias que protegían imagínense que
esas colonias fueran sus colonias a las
horas que sus hijos van a regresar de
estudiar a las horas que los
repartidores llegan a las tiendas oa las
horas que ustedes regresan del trabajo y
no va a haber nadie allí porque a una
tan sola persona le importa un poco
cruzarse la línea maria esto es parte de
los verdaderos impactos que puede llegar
a tener nuestras acciones cuando no
conocemos el espectro mayor de lo que
realmente puede causar y la siguiente
denuncia con responsabilidad mucha gente
dice yo prefiero no poner denuncias
porque la policía no hace nada porque la
policía ellos mismo le pasan la
información a las pandillas pero si les
preguntan en qué fundamenta eso cuál es
su argumento conoce cómo son los
procedimientos de como el 911 toma
que no son policías los que reciben la
llamada son teleoperadores entonces
cuando conocemos realmente el trasfondo
de cómo funciona esto debemos confiar en
la policía porque a quien más le van a
pedir ayuda y la policía si no hay
denuncias si no hay llamados va a
capturar criminales de formas
circunstanciales pero si ustedes
denuncian si ustedes nos dicen en donde
tenemos que empezar a trabajar así
realmente tenemos una línea para poder
atacar la criminalidad de otra forma es
muy difícil llegar a hacerlo estos tres
puntos son cosas muy básicas y sencillas
que ahora que conocen realmente el
impacto que puede llegar a tener pueden
ayudarnos para que nosotros hagamos un
mejor trabajo por ustedes y por último
como en algún momento el primer ministro
winston churchill hable habló su pueblo
en gran bretaña en uno de los momentos
más oscuros de la historia quiero
retomar sus palabras y decirles algo en
nombre de todos los compañeros que hemos
muerto por este país y por esta
población y todos los que seguimos
llegando y seguiremos en pie acá
lucharemos en las playas lucharemos en
las montañas lucharemos en los cantones
y en los caseríos lucharemos en las
residenciales y en las marginales
lucharemos en las planicies y en los
manglares lucharemos en todas partes
donde los salvadoreños nos necesiten
porque los héroes sin capas son ustedes
y somos nosotros solos juntos podemos
sacar adelante y crear el país que
queremos y nunca nunca nos rendiremos
gracias totales
[Aplausos]